this is the cloud atlas XD I doubt  there's more than a handful  but I know I know I know that's it the  music from my dream there are 0  movements i wrote imagining us meeting  again and again in different lives  different ages I can't explain it but I  knew and I opened that door a powerful  deja vu ran through my bones I heard it  in a dream is in a nightmarish cafe and  waitresses who had the same faith nor is  it hide I know you are sunny 451  yesterday my life was headed in one  direction stay  it is headed in another  never think the universe belief  phenomenon that determined the course of  our lives these forces begin long before  we are born and continue after repair it  I'm not our own  you're bound to others  past  I'm present  and by each crime  because I future  I  I believe there is another world waiting  for us a better world  and all the waiting for you there  you